welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss here with Jessica Clements and this
is a breakdown of Daredevil season 1
episode 3 rabbit in a snowstorm in our
Daredevil re-watch series The Road to
Born Again Jess are you ready for this
yes oh my god this is my way of doing
Daredevil if anyone sees me do this it's
not because I'm doing a mantis thing I'm
doing a daredevil thing green with the
green fingernails very fantasy
yes you guys Jerica is back at it this
week and we meet the big man himself
Wilson Fisk AKA Kingpin and if you come
at the king you best not miss if you've
watched Netflix's Darrell Elvis series
you remember this episode because
something horrible happens at the end of
it it's completely gruesome it's the
worst thing I've ever seen but either
way I'll be giving no spoilers as to
what it is so stick around until the
very end when you go see it and we're
gonna talk about it so let's just jump
into episode three right now after last
episode's awesome action-packed hallway
fight scene this week gives the fighting
just a little rest and instead focuses
more on the law playing out kind of like
an episode of Law and Order it's very
cool that this show can live in Two
Worlds both an action and an illegal
drama kind of how Matt himself moves
between two identities we open at
Whitestone bowling alley the color white
plays a big role in this episode and in
the first shot of the ball return feels
like it's straight out of The Big
Lebowski this entire scene feels like a
really horrific Big Lebowski the first
person we see in this episode is mobster
prahaska prohaska
who owns the taxis in Hell's Kitchen if
you remember in the first episode it's
mentioned by Anatolian Vladimir to
Wesley that fizz promised to handle him
spoilers he's gonna get handled real
soon oh yes he is prohaska Bowls the
game while his two bodyguards stand by
now this Frame does not go his way as
John Healy butts in asking to play and
he doesn't take kindly to being told
it's a private game and Healy kicks the
bodyguards booties Healy is inspired by
the comics character of Alvin Healey who
goes by the moniker Oddball and dude is
Scrappy as hell for a little guy he
pulls a gun upperhoska and we flash back
to 36 hours earlier that little 36 hours
earlier just feels like it came straight
out of the Tarantino movie yeah between
the coin brothers and Tarantino this is
one thing that like this early early
episodes of Daredevil always do they
always bring in these appropriate
stylistic influences that just shows
there's a lot of Cinema craftsmanship
going into this so Turk now opens this
box of guns which reads Firearms
contained in German look I know I look
like I'm someone who just can speak
German all the time but I don't I have
to look this up I promise I have to look
this up now Turk is a little worse for
wear after his last run in with the man
in Black but that didn't stop him from
selling these crappy guns to everybody
11 of them are already gone and Healy
tells Turk that he prefers a good
revolver because they don't jam up and
as Turk assures them this won't Jam we
get chekhov's jamming gun because we cut
back and it does exactly that to Fair
turkey did just say this baby will not
Jam or my name ain't turkey bear in the
comics he goes by several aliases so
this tracks sometimes its name is not
Turk Barrett in this case for Huska a
chance to smack Healy with that bowling
ball and says this is how he negotiates
huh referring back to how Wesley said
they were going to be negotiating in
episode one now yeah we know we know
what that meant prohaska gets taken out
with the very bowling ball he was
bowling with just moments before and as
the cops arrive Haley hides his gun
under a pinball machine with a sick ass
red 70s Barracuda on the side of it and
immediately asks for a lawyer that's how
every episode of Daredevil Born Again
should begin just someone doing
something horrible and asking for a
while yes yes I also only knew this was
a barracuda because for some reason a
lot of the Marvel Cinematic movies they
choose a 70s Barracuda a red one I don't
know why it's happened like two other
times but they love those 70s barracudas
we're only three and a half minutes into
this episode and one of the biggest
takeaways is the sound design if you
haven't yet please re-watch this episode
listen to the first three minutes of
this episode because they wanted to make
sure every sound was crisp insistent and
pulsating when the bowling ball comes
out of the ball return it sounds like a
car in a tunnel the low sounds of an
empty bowling alley the woman spraying
the shoes the light music the pins
crashing even the crunching of the man's
fine when Healy flips him is so
tumultuous if you close your eyes every
cut could make sense and I think this is
done to alert your hearing Daredevil
heavily relies on his hearing so we're
really feeling those sounds like feeling
those sounds it's like in your chest
it's like how we saw him fight in the
dark all the time it gives that same
depth to the episodes that aren't only
in the storyline but in the finished
physical products I eat this stuff up
you guys I took a sound design in
college then we get back to the best
intro that I've ever seen which I'll
never stop talking about we must pay the
toll every time we watch one of these
episodes and watch all the way through
these title cards and just gush on this
gushing because it's the best gushing
that you've ever seen so Matt is now
doing some deep thinking outside the
church until father Lantern still
probably think about Matt said was about
to do some bad stuff in the confessional
father sits down next to him and tries
to bribe him with an espresso if he just
talked to him about the previously
stated bad stuff haha nice try priest
you're not gonna trick me It also says
behind them Holy Eucharist Sundays 11
A.M to 5 p.m which the body of blood of
Jesus Christ is truly present on the
altar as Bread and Wine like I know this
is church but that's set up perfectly
between them why is that because he's
Catholic and if you don't confess your
sins you're not supposed to take the
Eucharist until you've confessed your
sins and done your Penance that's the
rule of Catholics we got rules you gotta
follow him so Matt have you truly done
your pennants until you do you can't go
get Jesus so we were introduced to Ben
yurich played perfectly by Vandy Curtis
Hall such a great character can we get
him to play Ben Huracan board again and
just pretend like that old little oopsie
the season won't happen anyway in the
comics he's a reporter who works for the
Daily Bugle the same newspaper as Peter
Parker which has changed the New York
bulletin for this show Bjork meets up
with Silvio an old school Italian
mobster who reminisces about the good
old days me and the boys driving in
Friday nights Kings in a castle Kings
don't have bodies in the trunk I went to
Macbeth yes Macbeth referring of course
to Macbeth murdering Duncan an ascendant
of throne but also there's at least one
other king who his body's in his trunk
we're gonna meet him at the end of this
episode Silvio is Silvio Manfredi we
talked about him in a past episode we
saw the man Freddy crime family and
Agent Carter and it's a man Freddy crime
family that Peter Parker disrupts in
that deleted sequence at the beginning
of far from home I still consider to be
MCU Cannon Silvio tells York that some
new player in town is killing off the
competition and he's getting out of
Dodge silio and Yorick both represent
the old guard there used to be rules
this represents the new guard which
follows no rules and is way more brutal
and it needs to be dealt with in a new
way with Matt's similarly brutal style
criminals used to play by certain rules
and you're used to expose those crimes
in the Free Press but as we're about to
see in the court case against Healy when
the deck is stacked in a criminal's
favor sometimes the only way to make
things right is to fight fire with fire
in a world on fire oh what a world on
fire in the Nelson and Murdoch office
foggy comes in still hungover from the
night before which means this episode is
happening directly after the events of
the last one which is crazy because
again Matt was messed up the fact that
he's even walking around today is that
all like is just a miracle upon itself
also how badass is Karen that she's in
the office looking fresh and not
distinctly hungover look at her
beautiful you can even still see the
imprint from the prison bed sheets are
still on her neck so she's having a hell
of a week and really foggy needs to stop
complaining because of the three of them
he's been living it on Easy Street 110
there's a knock at the door and it's
Wesley fist right hand man he uses a
jaunty knock that feels evil despite him
probably hoping to have the opposite
effect behind him is the door with Atlas
Investments logo which is a shout out to
Atlas Comics which eventually evolved
into Marvel Comics aha Wesley comes to
the office to hire the guys and he
really makes good use of this college
degree using this sense right here I
represent a Consortium with Diversified
interests in the private sector both
domestic and international yeah calm
down don't be stupid it's not the SATs
you're just being an [__] so Wesley
wants to hire Nelson and Murdoch on
retainer to represent Healy in all his
bowling ball bashing glory for a lot of
money and Matt is understandably a
little wary now this is good TV we are
playing Daredevil chess this back and
forth is so entertaining it sets up how
big of a figure Wilson Fisk is but also
leaves room for speculation why did he
dive so deep into their backgrounds how
does he know about Karen's charges how
does he know about the Intel fog he gets
from his cop friend Wesley's leaving no
room for error but completely digging
himself a big hole doesn't take a rocket
scientist to know that Wesley and his
employer are dirty crooked people so
that is why Matt follows Wesley outside
and tracks him by the ticking of his
Cartier watch and he even threw a
freaking Jackhammer construction and
just general city noise going on as well
he's able to hear it all a similar
Cartier watch goes for six thousand
eight hundred dollars this excess stands
in direct comparison to Nelson Murdock
being broke and Ben yurich struggling
with his wife's medical bills Crime Pays
kids and as Wesley gets into the car we
see the first glimpse of Fisk it's very
Dr Claw from Inspector Gadget right here
it's just his hand Justice cuff link
which will come to play in a big way
down the line and specifically through
the cufflinks is how the MCU
reintroduced Daredevil in that episode
of Hawkeye this guy speaks through his
cufflinks so Matt is bleeding through
his shirt as once again his job and it's
vigilantism Collide but he makes it into
the precinct to meet Healy just as foggy
decides he doesn't want anything to do
with him but Matt is desperate to find
out who Wesley works for so he takes the
case and we're gonna get to see some
good old-fashioned lawyer in this
episode and Ben Eric's office he argues
on the phone with his insurance and in
the background we see a framed article
with the headline to the Battle of New
York in reference to The Avengers and
another that reads Harlem Terror
referencing the events at the end of the
2008 Incredible Hulk Daredevil does not
care about putting they're like we'll
put in every Easter egg we want you guys
to know Ben argues with his editor
Mitchell Ellison played by Joffrey
Cantor about the kind of content that
they should be publishing there used to
be a time the people in this building
wrote the hell out of the news everybody
we know
is making twice what we are writing for
blogs working from home in their
underwear and again we get that old
versus new the sense that Ben is being
replaced by a more brutal world and with
no room for the pleasantries and rules
of the past spring is here finally and
now that it's nice out nobody wants to
spend all day in the kitchen save some
time with bacter they're fresh never
frozen meals are ready in just two
minutes so all you gotta do is heat
enjoy and then go back to the bark and
soak up that sun factor is America's
number one ready to go meal kit and yes
in other videos you'll hear me talk
about using hellofresh as well but
that's because factor is now owned by
hellofresh I use both of them and it
makes my life so much easier Factor not
only lets me skip the trip to the
grocery store I also get to skip the
chopping prepping and cleaning up Factor
has over 34 weekly options so I never
get tired of what I'm eating Factor now
offers the Gourmet plus meals as part of
your weekly options which means you can
get a little gourmet with your meal plan
whenever you're craving something
special for sides you get premium
produce like broccoli and broccolini to
perfectly complement your protein which
can be Surf and surf that's shrimp and
salmon
shrimp and steak and I can tell you from
personal experience even after reheating
the steak is so good it's not dry it's
not tough It's just good this month I
got an amazing chicken dish the
ingredients were all so fresh and it
tasted so yummy and it was super easy to
heat up and clean
oh that's so good got a nice sweet kind
of tanginess to it I love it so head on
over to factor75.com or click the link
below and use the code rockstars50 to
get 50 off your first Factor box once
again that's factor75.com and use code
rockstars50 to get 50 off your first box
Matt talks with heli about attorney
client privileges saying this then you
know anything you'll tell us stays in
this room just like church
Matt gets visibly uncomfortable At The
Mention Of Church no doubt thinking back
to his most recent confession and his
earlier rebuff of Father Lantern's
desire to speak with him some more which
is interesting is he losing faith in
himself or just religion values versus
belief it's it's a lot interesting yes
and Haley wants to go directly on trial
when he's indicted because as we'll see
he knows that he'll win no matter what
and he also refuses to tell Matt
anything about the man footing his legal
bills as for the man who hired you
all you need to know is
his check is going to clear Wesley goes
to retrieve the gun from the white stone
bowling alley and this guy knows his
arcade etiquette
thank you
I got next and back at Nelson and
Murdoch we go over the materials at hand
as a lawyer does the pros won the
bowling alley girl working during the
murder was in the back office until the
killing was done and didn't really see
anything go down two hilly has defensive
wounds three the men who survived the
goons refuse to talk Nelson and Murdock
are ready to go straight to court we
jump to the lawyer for the company
formerly known as Union Allied who tries
to pay Karen off for you know framing
her for murder and trying to have her
killed strong arming her into signing an
NDA and taking six months of salary to
put it all behind her and here's where
Karen has to deal with her own moral
compass will she take the deal or will
she continue to try and be a hero we
know what happens to Heroes at Hell's
Kitchen they get beat up they get a
bowling ball oh well that guy was a
villain that guy was still a criminal
that guy was still a criminal the guy
that got bowling balled but there are
innocent people that keep dying don't be
a hero or you're gonna end up at Metro
General Hospital here with Ben his wife
is there and clearly a long-term patient
we don't know what she's ill with but
he's trying to make sure she can get a
private room with assistance through
their insurance baggin Nelson and
Murdoch they're going over healy's case
and how they're going to handle it Court
foggy mentions wanting to win this case
and get more money and Matt's like
absolutely not money isn't everything
and it feels like morality is going to
be a big part of this episode like it's
a big part of the entire season but this
episode specifically the distinction
between right and wrong is really
important because Karen is dealing with
the bride foggy constantly looking the
other way when money's involved and
Ben's having to sacrifice his career as
an honest journalist to keep his job in
order to take care of his wife this is
important because we start to learn
everyone's motivations what really
drives them which we're not really
seeing from Matt right now he's not
really asking whether it's right or
wrong he's just doing it which could be
why he's avoiding confessing to
Fatherland him in the first place he's
just doing it without thinking about it
once the Wi-Fi comes back on we're
looking at foggy's page on the New York
penal law code specifically the use of
physical force and defense of a person
it's the longest most boring looking
document I've ever seen in my entire
life and this is exactly why I'm not a
lawyer I could not read that full thing
so we're at the courthouse with the
shakiest camera footage I've ever seen
that Steadicam and the New York wins
have zero chill funky gives his opening
statement and Matt starts listening to
the heartbeats in the courtroom sorry
foggy you you're boring but this God
damn but this case is all kinds of funky
so he knows how to play both sides of
vigilante and a lawyer that's when we
see one juror very nervous with a very
fast heartbeat and she is the mole get
her later that evening the blackmail
juror meets with one of his slackies who
reassures her that she doesn't want
whatever's on a tape of her when she was
19 to get out she's clearly at a loss
and having a hard time coping with the
fact that she's doing something
supremely illegal but again when
morality is put to play she chooses to
save herself which is what I would do
too so clearly no shame there other than
you know helping Jeffrey Epstein but
thank God Daredevil comes out of nowhere
and he starts beating this man up he
tells him to get rid of the footage he
says he can't and this Man reveals that
he doesn't really know his employer he
just does the job and Daredevil does the
job too he forces the man to get the
juror excuse and like that it works
she's excused also want to note that
this man in the window just watched
homeboy get his ass kicked by a man in a
mask and did absolutely nothing he's
literally standing there in the dark in
a window just watching this all happen
watching then we get the icing on the
cake the whole enchilada the whole
reason we're doing what we're doing in
the show I've been preoccupiedly with a
question morality sometimes the
delineation between the two is a sharp
line
sometimes it's a blur
and often it's like pornography you just
know when you see it morality it comes
down to morality we're wrapping this
episode up in a bow of morality bringing
Karen the juror foggy Matt and even
bends morality to the Forefront of this
episode so Matt lays it out the jurors
are important and their judgment is
important and let it be known his client
is pretty freaking guilty so it's up to
them to decide now we cut to Leland and
Wesley in a car speaking and truthfully
right here this is when I noticed it
though he's a very scummy person Leland
is a really great villain he thinks in a
very logical although horrible way he's
extremely transparent and quick which
mirrors his main job which is constantly
switching illegal accounts Wesley
reminds him with Rance Fisher McClintock
and Farnam they're leaving way too many
dead bodies behind so they need to stop
killing people like it's an accident
then we learn their game it's not their
experience that matters
they just opened shop and they're
completely clean they're using Nelson
and Murdoch because they're clean no one
can trace it back to Fisk when the boys
have such a clean record then Karen
thinks it's a great idea to go see Miss
Fisher the wife of Daniel Fisher the guy
that died in the first episode she's
currently moving and she's still
mourning her husband which is all very
sad and cumbersome she reveals that she
signed the former Union Allied NDA that
Karen was offered because she wants to
keep her children safe and wow it's
almost like morals are the common theme
of this episode it is everybody choosing
it's ah it's like okay I understand I
would do the same thing too and we
should mention that owlsley played by
the same guy who played Warden Norton in
the Shawshank Redemption a guy known for
tricky accounting that's what did him in
on that show so it's just kind of a
perfect casting everyone in the show
solo cast has a great body of work
behind them I love it but we're back
with Ben Uric who got good news from the
hospital but in walks Karen Paige and
she wants to talk about Union Allied her
moral compass is pointing right and Ben
is absolutely interested we're back in
the courtroom for the verdict and Matt
knows Wesley is there by the sound of
his expensive watch which is insane
that's genuinely very cool I love the
scene it's my favorite Power he's got
great hearing he's just a good listener
just a good listener hi oh that's all we
which is that's why that's how that's
how he's a boy he's a great listener
then he hears another fast heartbeat and
it's that older woman in the jury a new
mole she causes a hung jury and Healy
outwardly sarcastically commends Matt
for his beautiful speech earlier now
that he's off the hook and here's where
it gets gross I've seen this episode and
I know you have to and this has been
Daredevil gets dark this scene is almost
too inappropriate for TV we're gonna be
blowing it out here new rockstars
because you YouTube doesn't like this as
Haley's planning to leave Daredevil
sneaks it behind him and they start
going at it dumb Healy picks up a bucket
and a lead pipe in the middle of a fight
what'd you think was gonna happen bro
the loudest instrument he could have
ever picked up it's like picking up a
drum which is a horrible idea because
Daredevil hears it and immediately they
get back into the fight and Healy is
losing this is when they finally reveal
the name to Daredevil which is Wilson
Fisk we knew it Daredevil didn't know
his name yet he stabs Healy in the chest
with a broken Shard of a mirror he was
swung into this horrible fight is
concluded when Healy clocks out by
throwing himself I first on a serrated
Jagged metal Spike on a fence brutal I
mean come on could you no one would ever
do that no one would just know what
that's how I mean that's the best
introduction to a villain ever right it
literally this show is so good three
episodes Eric we are three episodes in
and this is a very horrifying way to die
but I'm also like oh we now are getting
the feeling of how horrible Wilson Fisk
is that you're so afraid that you gave
up his name that you have to get rid of
yourself This Way continue I love this
show so then we're introduced to Vanessa
soon to be fisk's everything she's an
art dealer and it's currently drawn to
Fisk immediately Vanessa tells Fiska
children's choco when you hold up a
white piece of paper and you ask what is
this and then you say a rabbit in a
snowstorm the title of this episode
which could summarize how Wilson Fisk
feels like a rabbit in the center of
this Hell's Kitchen mess this is one big
ass rabbit and he Blends in with the
city because everything everything is as
corrupt as he is so he never stands out
he's a man in the shadows by being
ironically framed in the brightest color
it's so bright it's overwhelming you
can't see anything it's a world on fire
for someone who is blind they hear so
much screaming so much pain and they
can't single it out but what's
horrifying about it is he believes he's
helping the cities maybe he believes
he's the innocent rabbit just being
stuck in a snowstorm that's why he wears
the color white he believes he is
morally pure on this Crusade when he is
anything but and what does he tell
Vanessa this painting makes him feel
alone
he'll stop that's what he is he's so
overwhelmed he's just alone but it's
also a pompous statement he's alone at
the top of this pyramid he's looking
down on the rest of the city and also
could of course be a call out to his
past with his father which we'll get
into later in our road to born again
and I'm hanging that with
j-e-s-s-i-c-a and that's the episode you
watched today hey thanks for watching
episode three of our road to board again
terrible re-watch series we're gonna be
back next week with episode four in the
blood subscribe to our new channel the
Deep dive you can watch a video I just
did about post-credit scenes and how
crazy they've gotten get smarter growing
Network by grabbing something from our
merch store nerdright.shop subscribe to
new rockstars on YouTube and all social
platforms follow Jessica at Lulu
underscore Clements you can follow me at
uavas and I'll see you next week
everybody
bye
[Music]